I like covering what's happening in the
news media world and one of the sort of
more interesting stories of the last
couple years has been megyn kelly who
started in media as a news reporter
after working as an attorney she then
became a contributor on Fox News she
ultimately got her own program on Fox
News and then she had this very public
spat with then candidate Donald Trump
where it was ultimately announced that
she'd be leaving Fox News to develop
programming for NBC News which would
include a weekly Sunday night program as
well as a daytime talk show and
immediately it was obvious that this was
a very clearly big big money for her
NBC News was sort of making a play on
Megyn Kelly's name rather than her
specific skill set or the demographic
that she appeals to and it was clear
that these weren't really her key
competencies or her sort of
bread-and-butter when it comes to format
and NBC News but a huge amount of money
on her write three-year 69 million
dollar contract crazy money but it has
been a total unmitigated disaster and it
keeps getting worse and back in October
we talked about it I told you things
weren't going well her nighttime
interview show they got Vladimir Putin
which was a big deal but otherwise
totally flopped they made a huge deal
out of their major blockbuster interview
with conspiracy theorist Alex Jones not
exactly the person you'd imagine a
program with this budget and this amount
of fanfare on corporate media would tout
as like a major get as one of their
first guests Alex Jones her daytime show
did okay for like a week then lost half
a million viewers within that at the end
of that first week and a lot of it was
Meghan Kelley just didn't seem authentic
in this format and it has continued to
get worse and worse since we talked
about this in October and there's a
really interesting Wall Street Journal
article about it now let's remember Wall
Street Journal is owned by News
Corporation News Corporation owns Fox
News
could they be writing a negative article
about megyn kelly because of sour grapes
it's possible but they're making
fact-based points and the fact-based
points are continued really low ratings
on the daytime show which have local NBC
affiliates unhappy
staffers on other NBC shows reportedly
upset about how much money Megan Kelly's
show gets despite the horrible ratings
Hollywood agents reportedly are telling
their clients not to even go on Megyn
Kelly's show because of low ratings and
because of this really weird incident
where megyn kelly interviewed Jane Fonda
not for very long it was a short
interview and chose to ask Jane Fonda
about plastic surgery and it did not go
well and then the nighttime show which
I'm barely talking about I'm barely
talking about it because it's been all
but canceled there's no weekly nighttime
show anymore
it's an occasional special episode like
a primetime special type of thing so was
this a mistake for megyn kelly I don't
know I mean financially not at all right
69 million for three years that's great
for her financially the problem is that
if she carries herself if she carries
her worth on more than just ratings and
on prestige then arguably this is a big
mistake
NBC seems to have really been the one
that made the mistake here right NBC
calculated that her personality
justified this amount of money and it
seems that this is bigger than megyn
kelly it seems like personality doesn't
drive corporate news shows to the tune
of 69 million dollars over three years
right there's no question that the big
personalities on corporate media do
Drive revenue but is it to the point of
69 million for three years apparently
not and corporate news ratings in
general have been down as there are
moral alternatives independently and on
the Internet some of Megyn Kelly's Fox
News demographics they don't really
translate to daytime talk shows right
typically the people that are watching
the nine PM partisan Fox News primetime
show or 10:00 p.m. whatever time she was
on those are not the same people
watching daytime talk and who would even
potentially be in Megyn Kelly's audience
so this has not worked well for NBC
megyn kelly is going to be fine
financially but I'm curious about the
future of this format bigger picture I'm
also curious how much longer NBC is
gonna allow the daytime show to continue
right I wonder what megyn kelly will do
after this three-year contract is up
yeah will and NBC re-sign are probably
for less money if they do
I don't think she can go back to Fox
News especially because there's probably
bad blood there she did write something
negative about Roger Ailes who allegedly
you know well he did actually I mean he
doesn't allege she was actually well
actually keep there were payoffs but of
course he passed away that I don't think
that their world to me any interpreted
proceedings there
yes but Roger Ailes by all accounts
massive payoff to gretchen carlson and
and other women i think she doesn't go
back to fox news for sure i think it's
possible that she gets shifted around in
NBC News she could maybe get reframed as
sort of just a news reader maybe she
becomes the next like half-hour news
person on NBC News but certainly a for
me the most interesting thing has been
whether or not she is a right-wing
ideologue the right-wing ideologue
character that she played on Fox News
does seem to have hurt her potential at
these new programs so total implosion of
Megyn Kelly's new shows both shows in
fact the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad